[music playing]
Cameron, Mike,
congratulations.
It is now down to the two
of you to decide who's
going to go home with the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
Now, this final
round of competition,
we're going to be sending you
guys back to your home forges
to build not one but two
iconic multi tools and weapons
from Russia.
And that weapon is
the Spetsnaz shovel.
Originating in the 19th century,
these all-purpose shovels
were adapted for use by
the Russian special forces,
the Spetsnaz.
These versatile
shovels were used
as entrenching tools, oars for
rafting, and even as cookware.
The Soviet military
units eventually
trained to use the Spetsnaz
shovel as a weapon.
The short handle is
made for quick moves
in close quarter combats.
These shovels featured
deadly sharp edges
that can be used for
anything from chopping wood,
to slashing flesh, or
even thrown at a target.
This utilitarian
tool can be seen
wielded in season 3
of History Channel's
hit survival series "Alone."
You guys will have four days to
work on your Spetsnaz shovels.
So good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck.
My name is Cameron Lafrance.
I am 20 years old from
Warner Robins, Georgia.
I got into metal works
thanks to my father.
It's really what sparked, no pun
intended, my drive for working
with metal and fire.
I have a lot of steel to
move and a very thin blade
to forge out, so
hopefully all goes well.
I start off with these two
pieces of leaf spring, just
to see if I can get it
forged down to parameters.
And then I noticed a piece of
W1 that I had laying around.
It's 2 inch round stock,
so I know for a fact
that it's enough material for
the job I'm needing it to do.
I'm going to keep
stretching it out
and then working on the width.
I got to still flatten
out one of my billets.
Woo, that's hot.
I'm getting the handle
and blade junction
merged up and then quenched.
I have to make sure that
they're both exactly the same
but still very confident
that I can do it.
That looks pretty badass,
if I don't say so myself.
I feel like I've
gotten to a place now
to wear my blades are
ready for the heat treat.
Here we go.
The sound I want to hear.
End of day three.
I am very happy to finally
have all these shovel
heads forged out, hardened.
Can't wait for a fourth
day to get these fit
and finished up and out of here.
I've had a lot of good luck in
my past with one special girl,
so I go ahead and
put my girlfriend's
name in Russian on
the handle, just
as a hopeful good luck charm.
And if it doesn't work,
then I know who to blame.
My name is Mike Powell.
I'm from Hastings, Florida.
I make blades as often as I
can, usually a couple of hours
in the morning before
work and then as much time
as my wife will let
me on the weekend.
She sacrifices a lot of
our one-on-one time for me
to be in my shop making blades.
If I win the 10,000, I'm going
to get my wife something nice
that we can enjoy together.
I'm going to forge
out these shovels
and see if I can win this.
I got it about
drawn out to length.
I haven't quite got
it as wide as I want.
I'm not sure I have
enough material.
I'll go cut me another piece
of steel for the second one,
drop it in the forge.
That ought to do it.
About three blows in--
Whoa!
--the whole end of the
billet just explodes.
Wow.
What the heck?
Never seen a piece
of steel do that.
Now I've got one piece left.
This sucks.
No way.
This is my third attempt.
Do over.
I take my time.
I keep my steel to
the right temperature.
It didn't explode on me
this time, so it worked out.
I never built anything
like this before.
I never even thought about
building anything like this
before.
But honestly, I loved it.
It was a challenge.
It was a learning experience.
It made me a better smith.
So I learned.
I gained a lot of experience.
And overall, it
was very exciting,
and I'm happy with it.
I'd say that's a matching set.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Can you dig it?
Well, I certainly can.
Your Spetsnaz shovels
look ready to go.
But what kind of lethal
damage can they do?
To find that out,
I'm going to take
your shovels to deliver
some lethal blows
of this ballistics dummy.
Cameron, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Cameron, let's talk
about your Spetsnaz shovels
here.
The weight is right, but
there is a little bit
of issue with your handles.
They're too smooth.
A couple of times,
it really felt
like it wanted to slip out.
They delivered nice cuts.
Thrusts are very effective.
And overall sir, it will kill.
Yes.
All right, Mike,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
All right, Mike.
Let's talk about your
Spetsnaz shovels here.
These are razor sharp.
Your handle construction-- the
one thing I didn't care for
was it's round.
When it's round, it can
go in different ways,
and I have to constantly
make adjustments.
But because of the ribbing
that you have there,
I was able to hold
on to it quite well.
Overall sir, your
shovels will kill.
Awesome.
All right, gentlemen,
you know what time it is.
It's time for the
strength test--
what we're calling
our throwing chop.
What I'm going to
be doing is throwing
your shovels into our targets
and then chopping on our fence
here.
What this is about is
not what your shovels do
to these targets, but what these
targets can do to your shovels.
Cameron, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Cameron.
For throwing, the
smooth handle is great.
That's not a plus
for chopping though.
When I'm chopping,
I'm constantly
kind of pulling it
back into my hand
because it wants
to slide forward.
This right here, this thin spot
where you've got that hammer,
it took a roll right there.
They threw well.
Good job.
Thank you very much.
All right, Mike.
You're up.
You ready?
- Yeah, I'm ready.
OK.
[music playing]
So right off the bat, the
finish work is really nice.
Your sockets are
really beautiful.
They threw great.
They certainly chopped fine.
I don't see any issues with
the edge of your blade at all.
These are definitely
well-made tools.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is a sharpness
test, the sandman slice.
Now unlike the strength
test, this is all about what
your weapons do to the sandman.
Cameron, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Cameron.
No issues with slashing and
chopping on the sandman.
Sir, your weapons will cut.
All right, Mike.
Your turn, sir.
You ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
All right, Mike.
Your edges are sharp.
Every cut was deep
and sliced nicely.
Overall sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
Well, gentlemen, you
guys should both be
very proud of yourselves.
We put your Spetsnaz shovels
through very hard tests.
As you know, there
can only be one
champion of "Forged in Fire."
Today's champion is Mike.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Cameron, unfortunately, that
means you didn't win today,
and Dave is going
to tell you why.
Cameron, what this came
down to is really two things--
your handle being as slippery
as it was and the damage
you took in the strength test.
For those reasons,
we're letting you go.
All right.
Cameron, you
definitely have what
it takes to fight in the forge.
You made it from
four down to two.
It was a close call.
But your time in
the forge has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you.
Take care, Cam.
I wanted to win it really
badly to prove to myself that I
can really go up
to the standards
as what other ABS master
smiths are able to do.
This experience,
it's really amazing,
and I couldn't have
asked for more.
Mike, congratulations.
That means you are today's
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You'll be getting a
check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I'm feeling amazing, like,
on top of the world amazing.
Mike, I was really impressed
on the finish you got on those.
It's really nice, clean
from top to bottom.
Well done.
Thank you.
I build knives for a hobby.
From this point on
though, I really
want to concentrate on
doing real high end work
and just improve my skills.
[music playing]